guns guns guns guns guns you're watching
selected clips from Republican senator
Gary Goodman's counter filibuster to
prevent the passage of a gun bill once
again we find the Democrats politicizing
a national tragedy in order to push
their anti-gun agenda guns are under
attack America is under attack did you
know that the word gun is one button
away on a computer keyboard from being
the word fun coincidence gun control is
fun control today I am proposing that we
change freedom to free gun that's right
I'm a free gunfighter and you know what
free gun isn't free except in this case
it is I'll stand here as long as it
takes I don't care I'm at work right now
I'm making money right now I was elected
every citizen in this country should be
armed in order to protect America from
Isis from al-qaeda from Ebola from
people with more guns than you Obama
here's an illustration I drew of what
usually happens during a mass shooting
All Right see that helpless and here's
what would happen if they all had guns
boom boom boom boom boom this is how you
keep America safe yeah I know what the
critics will say or how will we know who
the active shooter is I'm scared it's
simple they'll look like this it's weird
you get really sweaty when you have to
pee free gun-free God all free gun yeah
freak aah aah I'd like to present you
with a few ideas I came up with in lieu
of oppressive gun control legislation
Kevlar for babies pray better force
fields no more congregating just stay
inside where
safe because everyone's got guns now I
am thirsty I do not like green eggs and
ham although I will defend to the death
your right to eat them Uncle Sam I am
gun copters hey I got a surprise for you
guys while you run it why are you scared
you think I want to be here I want to go
home the NRA won't let me someone tell
my what okay I mean you know who else
trying to ban guns Hitler so are you
thanks for watching the sea spam network
government in action